hey everybody we've got a special
announcement
i know we have been talking about an
exciting week this week and we are going
to be switching things up a little bit
stephen and i have been working
furiously behind the scenes on some
exciting new stuff that's going to be
happening you're going to see the fruits
of those laborers in january
but we've moved up the timeline on
getting that work done so steven and i
are going to be taking that time this
week to work on these things
but in the meantime we're going to be
answering some incredible requests that
we've had
for content with the hodge twins and
some never seen footage from 2020
and talking about other fun things this
week to lead everyone off into having a
very merry christmas
no matter how much biden and kamala want
to destroy this country
so we'll see you there
it is right before christmas and
everybody is getting ready for that big
sleigh ride on the night of the 24th
christmas eve see all these toys are
made by these
elves these elves have that certain
knack for toy making
all except for this this one
misfit herbie
aren't you finished painting that yet
there's a pile up a mile behind you
what's eating you boy well see that's
the problem i guess
what i just don't like being a boy
how well if that's all what
you don't like being a boy
now hermie doesn't like being a boy
hermie doesn't like being a boy hermie
doesn't like being a boy
he doesn't like being a boy
well sir someday i'd like to be a
a lady oh lady well we need one up here
see i've been studying and there's
hormone blockers and
bottom transition surgery and fate now
listen you you're a boy elf and boy
elves stay
boy now get to work
[Music]
10 minute break
not for you finish the job
or you're fired
why is he such a trans foe
i can't stand wearing men's clothes
chop my dick off with gu stow
then i might fit in um
we have to go oh don't we have uh we
have actually uh to check in with our
los
angeles traffic report it's a
contractual obligation uh los angeles
traffic this morning uh with thomas
finnegan on the ground
mr finnegan what do you got for us sir
morning steven
uh i'm here on the 405 and uh
um
thomas can you hear us tom tom
oh oh thomas finnegan what's going on
steven uh can you case
set me up with get gabby yeah the gap uh
you mean gabby.com crowder yeah yeah
i'm trying to to do the the paperwork
online but
uh it's asking me for my information
yeah yeah so no yeah people who don't
know their sponsor gabby.com
you go it's it's free and actually you
enter in your insurance information
and then it shows you where you can get
a better rate because a lot of people
get locked into insurance for years and
don't realize that right
better rates elsewhere yeah okay i i
put in all my information but it's
it's not it's not giving it to me it's
not giving you what
it's not giving me the the insurance
wait yeah no you have to enter in your
insurance information to see are you
trying to get insurance right now
thomas finnegan
i won't go back okay all right let's let
uh thomas finnegan go
and by the way people who don't know
that's gabby.com crowder you get a free
uh check
i was shocked that's fantastic right
shocked how much all it is is you just
go and you check it and they don't sell
out any of your information by the way
privileged i think yeah i think i've
heard that they like customers save like
an average like 900.
it's something that's wild i thought
there was a mistake
right it's a pretty easy process i
looked i was like really just because
i've been paying insurance for a very
long time and then they don't give you
the discounts because you just get used
to paying for insurance so gabi.com
crowder and uh because you enter in uh
our url you will get it for uh free
a free check
[Music]
so gabby car insurance if you haven't
already tried it i've gone there go i
went to the website
i put in my information for my current
insurance went in there
they did the magic behind the scenes
gabby.com and when you go to check out
gabby.com
crowder now people who are using gabby
including myself these are the folks who
are saving on average per year 961
dollars
i got a speeding ticket the other day
and i put it in
i knew my insurance was going up and the
savings that i was able to get through
gabby.com is great
here's the other thing i know we're all
out here fighting big tech
we're all here steven's leading the
fight i'm trying to help and what's
important about that is gabby.com
doesn't sell your data
they're not out there like google
youtube all these other companies making
money off of your data
they aren't selling it so make sure to
go out and support them they're
supporting us
they're here knowing we're probably
going to get canceled at some point
gabby.com
crowder get your insurance save that 961
dollars per average
year get there
here we go ash wednesday yeah everybody
with me at the hodge twins in studio
today how are you
keith and kevin got me some cigar action
going yeah now which one's kevin which
one's keith
wait what'd he say and we have a quarter
black garrett
hey what's up audio wade half asian bill
hello uh i have a great cigar today new
world from aj fernandez
that's a really interesting story a guy
who uh trained in cuba
okay there's a guy named robina who made
all the cigar wrappers for castro and
the cohibas oh and then the cuban
government started taking 90 percent of
their crop and
this guy went in damn four guy he was
lebanese went to fled went to cuba
then cuba now he's in nicaragua poor son
of a [ __ ] can't catch a break hey aka
steven that's just poor decisions it's
like someone right now in the united
states and black guy going like i don't
like the way blacks are treated here i'm
going to go to cameroon
well watts good luck in cameroon
worse off go to china man that would be
terrible why
why why do you hate your own people i
don't hate my own people they hate
themselves
that's fair he's a self-loathing china
man
no jeez we'll see now that's just see
this is one of the few areas where white
people can say it doesn't have the
connotation
because the black people are the ones
who created the [ __ ] thing oh i'll
correct them when they're wrong but
they got to be wrong first uh
so i guess my question of the day to you
guys since we're going ash wednesday is
uh what do you like
on the show when it's non-political what
do you want to see more we do mass
mondays we do ash wednesdays
uh also gerald is not dead he had a baby
he's going to be back
very very soon and so
a little bit for the first couple of
months because you know babies they
always whine
um they take work i don't know babies
i'm not entirely sure what happens when
you leave the room i don't know if they
still exist
i want to see uh i want to see brendan
climbing more polls
yeah in the middle of the night that's
the thing well he did have to pay his
way through college so
there's some footage of that somewhere
let's go first to your questions you can
always send them to louderwithcredit.com
ask okay that's where we get your video
questions so we take fresh wednesday but
first actually we have a pairing of the
week
correct of the week yes from carolina
cigar man
olivia milanio five with
wood woodford that's sir that's a v what
that's a v i don't even know how you
misread that it's five
like i could understand if you said like
a u
come on or like roman numerals bro he's
part roman oh
roman numerals that was a five you know
what recorded smarter than me
here i was thinking about getting into
quantum theory i forgot about roman
numerals
nobody bring out an analog clock i don't
know what
so uh let's go now this came to us from
a lot of credit.com
ask a video question hey guys i have an
ash wednesday topic for you
i want to hear how each one of you met
each other
and how you grew that friendship into
a quality male friendship as someone who
moved across country about a year ago
um just want some uh examples of how to
cultivate relationships like that hope
to hear this
topic discussed look forward to smoking
with y'all
well that sounds so sexual
but i think this question should be
tossed to half asian bill because uh he
talks about
uh friendship like it's a bonsai tree
bill i do you have to get
little very little tweezers and then you
poke them at people and the ones that
don't hit you or yell at you become your
friends no
uh so so look i'm not i'm not from texas
and i didn't know anyone here literally
the when i moved here to go to law
school
i didn't know anyone i just went and
bought furniture and food and then i got
fat no and then i started law school and
then i made friends but the way
you do that is you look for a lot of
like foreigner comic jokes today like
then i gained weight i kid but my wife
she's [ __ ]
so uh yeah so she you know so she's
actually not a [ __ ]
no that was a joke no no no no i know
that you've read these in eastern uh
european uh icebreakers like a book
yeah exactly i needed to get those out
of my system but uh
here's here's what i say this is what i
say you got to do one you know how did
we meet we met through
a mutual friend a friend of your brother
she's a friend of yours who who's a
genius yeah who is a friggin jean who's
a genius who you would meet
and at first meeting and i said i
absolutely adore you jordan
people would think like he's not a
genius no when you first meet him
because he's
so blunt yes he's so matter-of-fact uh
he remember he
i don't know if you know that so he he
was a so let me and i want you to
continue but this is a guy who we became
friends with i became friends with from
i don't know how he became friends with
jordan but he's the one who introduced
you and i uh because he was the only
lawyer friend i knew
he went to harvard uh and i knew ben
shapiro at that point couldn't help me
with the uh
he wasn't no longer practicing law with
the facebook was it saturday but um
yeah no that was when i asked him to
flip hey can you flip on that light
switch
no i'll get it
that's not the reason i would ever want
to be demonetized
so this guy jordan is brilliant where he
was he was like a
pothead in high school was kind of a he
was kind of a screw-up and then he met
this girl
who told him to get his act together i
was like no no listen you're going to
make something in your life he's like no
okay
and then i said okay you're going to get
into harvard he was like all right fine
and so then he became a straight a
student went to community college
got to ut then went to harvard and
graduated [ __ ] laude
and in the summer he found out that he
could rebuild jaguars because most
people weren't working on them and they
were very unreliable cars and he made
like
six thousand dollars a car yeah and he
would be just he's a harvard law grad
would be just as happy being a mechanic
yeah he's
a brilliant person and you're just like
thank god he's on our side
but if you talk to him he's like hey how
did you started flipping jaguars i made
like
36 000 in a month and uh now i'm going
to harvard so whatever
you know i just go with that and i love
him dearly because he's going good he's
amazing so i met him
and his wife randomly at a just a young
lawyer's industry professional
happy hour and it just came from
randomly talking to people and taking an
interest in what they
are you know interested in finding
things to connect over
and then you know just maintaining that
friendship and you know
you know and it's especially hard right
now in covenant especially when you're
moving across country
but when you go somewhere don't let
anyone tell you that there aren't people
like you where you're at even in places
like california
where you know we talk a lot about
california for good reason
but there are yeah i mean anywhere in st
louis um
and uh you know but you're gonna find
people that have similar
interests as you that have similar
beliefs that have similar you know
things
whether it's jiu jitsu or shooting
sports or whatever it may be right
um and you just gotta go you gotta put
yourself out there it's a numbers game
yeah and then i think as far as how you
cultivate those relationships that
everyone kind of values different things
and
i'm someone who's never had uh a lot of
friends but i've always had really
a close-knit circle of friends so what i
value kind of above everything else is
is honesty and loyalty and um and what
that means is not blind loyalty but it
means that even if someone thinks you're
screwing up you know we have
accountability partners you know gerald
is a great example
um i think everyone here you know we
really do have stand-up men here we have
some great uh some great danes who work
here too
um loyalty to me someone who will be
loyal enough to make sure that i don't
embarrass myself and will
be critical of me when needed and doing
so in love but also
have my back if so if i can't be friends
with someone who you feel like
is going to be just you know like
bananas in pajamas when they run just a
cloud of themself when the crap goes
down
that for me is a really kind of
important metric
um for close friends and then you have
casual friends where you share interest
and i don't really remember how we met i
just i was a fan of you guys for a long
time because you did the fitness channel
yeah and um i used to you know when i
was younger hide it from my parents
and uh then we had reached out to you a
couple of times and you had an agent who
was like nah they're not interested it
turns out it never got to you yeah that
was my black manager
oh okay i don't wait to bring race into
it uh
well it's very important she's black and
uh she was managing us at the time and
she was like korean hollywood he's
conservative stay away from that man
yeah so she wanted us out of politics oh
well
that was a good thing we fired her yeah
she was a horrible manager people were
careful we don't need any black on black
not crime but smears today that's also
an epidemic
uh so and then then i think darren who's
a booker on the show
because everyone else was afraid to
similar probably like you guys having
managers you know you have to cycle
through them because they go don't do
what you're doing if you want to work in
this industry
he reached out i think to you guys
directly or your new agent and included
a quote
that you guys it's just advice fellas
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do that's what you guys used to say
yeah you gotta call this guy back well i
think you realize that people actually
followed your stuff yeah it was amazing
to see i had no idea he was watching my
stuff
or hey you may want to go on stephen or
he's a big fan
or a 60 year old white man and my dad
yeah hey
hey uh steve i gotta give you some props
man you helped me come out as
conservative man
that was an accident you pushed me out
of this i did not
i did not i did not it's like
you sound
no i had you on and i asked because i i
i thought and this is true i thought
that you guys were more conservative
than you realize i said former marines
business owners i read an interview with
you guys in the rob report a long time
ago of all places i must have picked it
up at an airport
um and uh i said these are guys who are
probably more inherently concerned and
then when i started
speaking with you i just wanted to reach
out i think at that point because i just
wanted to have you as guests yeah yeah i
think we started talking and i did say
before i'm like and you don't have to
discuss anything
you're not comfortable with and then you
know you uh
you got the hate mob after you yeah i
mean
because she was advertising right beside
our videos
yeah because it like was getting a lot
of messages every day for my black fans
and it's like oh my god i lost all
respect for you guys
you're on that white supremacist show
yeah that's like how did they find that
video and i'm
looking at my videos there's a stephen
crowder advertisement
on your videos yeah right beside our
video yeah man i don't know maybe it was
an advertisement maybe it was yeah
it was suggested yeah exactly back when
i was still suggesting yeah yeah i
forget the type of video we was talking
about obama
yeah yeah it was hodge twins hate obama
click here now
and please end career and comments
no but we've talked about this and
talking about loyalty now you have i
mean your uh conservative twins
passed a million subscribers and that
happened really quickly yeah and you
said you guys have fans now who are far
more
loyal man oh yeah yeah i mean we we had
some good fans before we came out of
this casino no no they sucked
yeah they sucked they was broke they
were terrible it was a bunch of liberals
we was in
florida right right and it's this older
couple right it was a uh was it orlando
yeah right after the show we're doing
our meet and greet and the guy comes up
and he's like dude
i gotta get your shirt man i'll give you
each 250 bucks just give my shirt i'ma
give it to my wife
oh she's gonna really like it man oh man
right i didn't know she was there did we
show up with a telescope
so we take our shirts off yeah not like
a merch shirt
like the shirt your shirt off yeah
during the show
was this a white guy there's a seven-day
white guy oh that's a problem
it turns out it was that's why it was
ill-fitting
and then we take the shrimps off he's
like oh man
dude man y'all looking good man
and then his wife said oh my god they
took their shirts off and she comes
running from the back and we're up on
stage i'm like this is going to turn
into
into some cuckhold action yeah you know
if you guys take part like it's not i
mean you know that's
that's on you you know what's funny
though you know what's funny our wives
were there and it was standing
at backing like two mexican immigrants
it's just like
[Laughter]
to be clear their wives are actually
mexican immigrants oh
jesus they were just saying they were
looking they were standing like two
mexicans for people who don't know your
wives
that's what it sounded like always stand
in those mexicans
you don't got their two legs
mexican legs stephen how come is it
always that
uh your your favorite minority people on
the show all have mexican wives
that is that is true isn't it it is well
my first wife scarred me
i said i'd never date another black
woman
well that's horrible because he can't
you know there's some there are plenty
of nice
well there are some good black women but
the one that she used to be
they're out there somewhere
but the one i uh i was actually married
before to a black woman she still
beat my ass really well yeah wow and you
know she's
like babe please stop hitting me you
liked it or you didn't get your [ __ ]
together
what did she have a point no i was
really nice i was in the marines at the
time okay
yeah so you know i i also i have never
your wife
oh no i mean yes with with a sandal
she'll take it off and
oh okay but uh i'm not into asians
because you know they all look like my
mom
so i
because you know the quote is going to
be in the next mashable article though
steven didn't say it himself
on his show was i would never date an
asian woman because it looks like it was
a guy with asian i don't know why you
think that's relevant
you're the son of a [ __ ] go ahead
you're supposed to be you're supposed to
keep you're supposed to be good to me
you're my lawyer you're supposed to
protect me so good all right so
so you don't like asians can i say one
more thing on the front thing because i
do think it's a good question like
the different people in on this
particular show and the people behind
the scenes in front of scenes like these
guys you know wade and
quarter black you know every one of them
has something very interesting that
they're doing and if you're interested
in other people
you will find the common ground that you
have in cool things like
talking about movies talking about books
talking about whatever it may be even
just
you know waiting not talking about kids
like you know yeah all that kind of
stuff right and
and if you can reach out to people and
be willing to put yourself out there
you're gonna run
i have had people who are like i
literally do not like anything about you
yeah and i actually okay appreciate that
like okay
great i'm going to like stop we're
trying to i remember that conversation
in the green room
four minutes before you don't need to
jog my memory yeah it was not that long
ago um
so you know that's what you're gonna do
if you're gonna put yourself out there
you're in a new city
find someone go to a church go to an
organization go join a sports league go
go down to the shooting range whatever
it may be yeah you're gonna start
talking to people you're gonna find
people and you're gonna be
surprised yeah like he was a local
ping-pong hall yeah and it's a tough
time
right now with going on i'm sure that
it's like
bill started it moving to a new spot
yeah i would
i wonder how bill clinton met epstein um
were we staying there wade before it was
taken from 60 to zero
i was just saying it is a tough time to
make new relationships
with covet and everything but i'm i and
depending on the area where you are some
things are probably open
figuring out a new place i mean places
where people gather and meet are usually
closed right now so that's true
um yeah i i can i recognize that that
would be a tough thing
now um but yeah any kind of advice on
that and
maybe we could approach it the cigar fan
is on right a little bit no
no it's not speaking of tough yeah we
have a cigar fan that
sucks out this whole room in about 30
seconds and you don't but if you don't
turn it on
you get cancer um and then i get fired
so no i mean and also the problem too
with the covet is also the mask because
the second i put that on i want to break
stuff
yeah cause it's like no one's gonna do
anything i'm just gonna go i just wanna
rob and pillage
yeah that's what i wanna do yeah give me
all your money
it's an instinct i think that probably
the people
uh who i can think of uh if you were
obviously uh
committing your crimes in tandem where a
mask would be the least effective in
concealing your identity would be the
hajj
twins yeah also you're wearing merch
[Music]
yeah so uh as far i don't know with that
i mean there are some cigar lounges that
are open that are actually still pretty
good places and you meet a lot of good
people um there are some places where
you can do some sporting events you know
places that aren't
i really hate that the church has really
just sort of backed down a lot of places
where it's like if you can be out in the
streets and protest if the church is so
terrified about the optics of doing it
inside you can do church in the park
i've done that before
and the churches that are meeting are
really growing right
like a lot they're they're over capacity
right now the people the people who are
meeting yeah maybe find an area a church
in your area that is meeting a sports
league that is meeting you could find a
way it's got to be tough yeah
yeah and will there's a way there's a
will and then also some news grinder
so um look and i remember gordon
blackhead the way i met him was he came
in
at that point we needed an editor and
we've talked about this before where um
uh quarterback wasn't you know editing
wasn't his strong student comparison to
people who we
have who are like more like technical
editors but we really like
no i'm not trashing your head but come
on do you really think you can do what
brendan does
oh no he's a magician no he's a magician
he's like douglas with the remote
control
um but ask him to warm up spaghetti
noodles
can't do it it's just a house fire
waiting to happen some people have
certain skills but you had but he had a
great attitude he was
he was great at doing a lot of things
and making sure that he got in there and
i also also
did a crowder confronts later on um at
the uh the open minds the d
this democratic state convention if you
go back and watch that video you see
garrett saying like all right let's go
let's go he's like a little he's like a
bow evil just like ready to go and i was
like okay
let's let's move him into a bigger uh a
more uh responsible
role you know where he has more under
his purview and he's really he's really
grown into it
i think if you expect the best of people
and this is a big problem with the
democratic
party is if you tell people they're not
good enough and you tell them
that the system is is stacked against
them then why
try whereas i think that if you do and
of course you have to this is why i say
that first
sort of litmus test the loyalty the
character the honesty because if you
don't have that
then none of the then the rest of this
doesn't matter and you can be kind of
friends with those people if like your
kids are in the same activity you know
golden swimmers whatever it is that kids
do a little goldfish thing but you're
not going to actually have them
in your corner um but once you have that
if you actually
expect more of people you kind of speak
them and treat them to the
level that you know they can be maybe
they aren't there now usually
good people honest people will rise and
i do think that's an important thing
right now that
we don't really do a whole lot we tell
people that you can be anything you want
to be
and uh you know just believe in yourself
which i don't even believe i believe
that of course as a christian
you're not all you need that you do need
god but then these same people who say
all you need is self-belief and they say
also uh all you really need is to tear
down
all of this country's institutions
policies offices
uh otherwise you can't make it um and
it's the same thing with friendships
speak people and treat people to the
level that you want them to be
if they're not there yet i think i think
the first thing that maybe you noticed
whenever i first
came here is uh i actually cared
you know like it's it was in a time
where it was like you were really
stressed out about a lot of different
things and then there was one time
uh something bad happened it was you
know loyally things
and uh you were like stressing about i
was like hey man
yeah are you okay what's going on i like
sent you a uh yeah
no you're some stuff and i care you know
yeah so you got to do that you got to
start you stretch out you're caring
for other people and they'll come to you
yeah that's true except that time that
you were drowning in my back pool and i
laughed
i mean you can't not laugh i don't i
don't put that against you
no actually carrie no that that is a big
thing and remember we had another we had
other people who uh with golden thing
with a guy who came in
who would leave for smoke breaks like
cigarette breaks i heard about this yeah
it was before i got a great idea what do
we do this thing like jurassic park like
he basically would like pitch a michael
bay field
ideas and they'd be like oh okay how are
you gonna do it like i gotta go get a
marlboro
i'm gonna mull it over them so you
didn't have a tough act to follow
you've flourished since but initially
just anyone came like oh thank god
[Music]
yeah looks like you got it
[Music]
noise
[Music]
millions of pieces pieces for me
yes millions of pieces pieces for me
drag millions of pieces
[Music]
all right spartan armor systems guys
they have gone out on a limb to sponsor
the show
before we get canceled but spartan
armorsystems.com they're having their
biggest promo ever this christmas the 12
days of tactical giveaway
they're going to have 12 prizes over 5
000
12 orders will be refunded 20 off site
wide and with that promo code
crowder you're going to get free betsy
ross hat and morale patch this runs from
the 11th
to the 23rd i mean look at this thing
this thing can stop so much it's not
going to stop
uh the glitter bomb that's going to come
from every package and bag and cards you
get this season
but it protects you from the things you
really need to so make sure to go to
spartanarmorsystems.com
and use that promo code crowder for your
free betsy ross hat morale patch
20 off and these 12 prizes during the 12
days of tactical giveaway
so um yeah hopefully it helps on the
friendship question um
we have one more question from again you
can send your questions to uh a lot of
credit.com
ask for the video questions but i think
we have some tweets as well oh oh i
should say
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed because subscriptions don't
really mean a whole lot and do consider
joining mug club because you get an
extra 45 minutes every day with these
shows
and it's also the only thing that allows
these shows to exist period
you notice there aren't a ton of ads
we're not reading for every you know
gold and bed sheets and uh scalp
treatments and shaves dollar bills that
shave you
um because we are actually sponsored not
by federal grants but viewers
like you uh we have another question
right so they asked
talk about how to go about life without
being political
agree to disagree is that possible
anymore
um no i mean that's the wrong show to
ask this is why you're asking
here's the thing i think agree to
disagree having a civil diso
there's a difference between a civil
disobedience yeah there's a civil
disagreement and agree to disagree
i don't really like you agree to let
live you know what i mean
but as far as like we just agree to
disagree and we're gonna be best buds
that's pretty tough to do i don't think
it's possible
people used to say don't talk religion
in politics the two things that matter
most
now there are times where it's
appropriate there are times where it's
inappropriate and for example you don't
need to
you don't need to choose someone's ear
off about politics if you're watching
your kids soccer game
but as far as as this relates to our
question earlier in
fostering relationships that matter um
i just can't see in 2020 how you could
have that trust in someone uh if at the
very least
you don't even know where they line up
politically yeah you have to know at
that point so then before you can agree
to disagree you have to know where you
disagree
and so for me i have more respect and
probably more trust for someone who
would tomorrow join the soviet red army
than someone who's like i don't know i
just stay out of politics that's like
well then you're just going to stay out
of
any confrontation which means i can't
trust you well yeah and then slowly but
surely
politics will start to care about you so
yes you've got i mean you can walk out
and if you're not wearing a mask
in the middle of austin when we were
there it's like you get you
get what two thousand dollar fine yeah
so it's like yeah it's like well i'm not
really a political person well
if you put on a mask or don't put on a
mask you are doing it's gonna come for
you have you ever written a check to the
irs
right yeah do your kids go to public
school right do you
care about uh lives you care about
abortion does that matter to you do you
think you should be able to go to church
you know if these things for someone to
say those things don't matter to me
or what matters more to me is avoiding
all confrontation
so i just don't talk politics that means
it's someone who really doesn't value
their values for lack of a better word
uh or someone has never thought of these
issues and that's dangerous too because
then all of a sudden they think they've
discovered something new
and they go off half cocked and they
don't really and i've seen that too
where people had never really thought
about politics before
they never really even thought about
what mattered to them before and then
all of a sudden they think
i've got it figured out and they get
half the information that's not someone
you can trust
or there's some figure that comes out
and it's like oh this is the person
maybe it's bernie or something like that
right even ron paul and it's like we're
even trump
yeah or trump and we get excited about
some figure and whatever he says and
yeah you're
not really able to that's the principle
yeah sort through what the values are
and
though that's where the heart is i get
excited about hidden figures
oh yeah they i don't know i don't know
which one from mama who was in that i
don't know let's continue what are we
about to say
is that the one with the nasa astronauts
yeah the black lady astronauts the black
space people right no they were the
mathematicians mathematicians they were
there they were real
unsung heroes you know what we did was
we sent the white guys up there
because they were expendables yeah yeah
exactly because a lot of them
the expendables yeah the story was told
they were where they were you know it
was like well white guys were the ones
who got all the credit they probably
went to those black women and were like
hey brother would you like to go into
space like
what's that involved well you know you
could just uh crash uh it could
completely burn apart uh when exiting
your atmosphere
or yeah or you could sit here and do
some math that's why people
i do long division
[Laughter]
from this atmosphere
with gravity you know you know those
ladies they were very grateful for
staying in america yeah or those
astronauts they couldn't wait to get out
yeah yeah i don't know how many people
of color were involved with sputnik
probably probably a few yeah probably
very few it's a little bit monotonous
what do you
yeah what do you want to say go ahead i
was gonna say you know and it also comes
to
thinking about the trust question is
really important because
we've talked about this question before
about you know if you were gonna date
someone or marry someone that has
you know widely differentiating more
moral views or
um you know beliefs and that kind of
thing and how difficult that can be
because you need trust
but you know by the same token like i
don't you know i don't go roll up to
quick trip and start
quizzing the guy behind the counter
before i buy a monster you know and so
you know like you can work with people
in certain settings you can interact
with people you can be at a ball game
you can be
you know at a movie theater or whatever
and not have to engage in all that stuff
and and
you know force everyone to go through
and i know people like that they'll go
say yeah well i gotta ask everyone there
if they are methodists
if they're not methodists you know then
you know if they read the bible then
they're not methodists so
we definitely uh you know so we we want
to make sure and i go come hey guys we
gotta we're getting we're in the
country is built on having people who
are other and sure maybe you're not
gonna engage in a conversation with
everyone and maybe you're not gonna
trust your kid
or your marriage to someone that has
those kinds of views but you can still
interact with them and
look leading look this is the thing that
we always have to combat
um in different ways is the idea that
conservatives are the uncaring
party right or the uncaring set of
morality when in reality
we are the ones dealing with the reality
of you have to make hard decisions and
hard choices
and those can be sticking with people
who have the same morality if they're
coming in
it's good that you put it that way i
think it's important that it's the idea
because i think it was uh was it david
brooks i believe who wrote the book who
really cares it was about you know
listen it's overwhelming if you look at
the people who are the most charitable
red states and then christians that is
what defines someone and not just giving
to churches
but also giving to charities that aren't
their church it's not even close the
least charitable people tend to be
poor liberals so you get middle class
red state christian conservatives give
the most and then you get wealthy people
give the most
wealthy liberals give more than
middle-class liberals so there's there's
this whole um
you can see these statistics you can
find them online but it stands to reason
because
listen we don't believe that a
centralized government is
effectively a form of charity we don't
believe we've thrown more money at
education we've thrown 22 trillion
dollars the war in poverty hasn't worked
but we can see
in our neighborhood directly like we we
my wife and i give to a small church
where we got married
and the reason why is listen our tithe
makes a difference there we can see
that there was a lady who had her roof
ruined during a big storm
up in northern michigan and our tithe
along with one else's tithe
went to fixing that roof we can see how
it serves the community
as opposed to writing a check to
washington and hoping for the best right
that kind of spray and pray mentality so
it is important
when people understand that they have to
take it upon themselves to help their
fellow man
and not the next guy will do it that's
how you end up with joe biden who gives
less than one percent to total chair the
least charitable president
ever joe uh barack obama least
charitable vice president ever
joe biden yeah and then you have bernie
sanders who
to the absolute decimal right like he
was in hidden figures doing math for the
spaceship when he tips it's eighteen
point five percent and that's indicative
of someone who's a huge level that's
indicative of someone who really has a
problem
parting with money and um yeah i think
that's a problem uh that you well
statistically it's undeniable
on the left let's clarify only parting
with his own money yes
not your money and and i think tolerance
we're finding out is not
a current left-wing value so i think the
question assumes that there can be a
certain amount of tolerance a certain
amount of like difference of opinion
and we're okay with sitting around with
people who disagree and that's that's
okay but that is
sort of at least right now almost
exclusively a conservative
value the the people who are okay with
having even though that's what they put
on their
letterhead yeah exactly they're like
we're tolerant yeah yeah yeah
bigots yeah the co-exist even though the
c wants to eat all the letters
hutch wins well you know when y'all went
from the you know that's because he
can't tell you
into the cons that's correct that's
right i mean i heard what you said but i
wasn't looking so i don't know which one
no but but you know when you've seen
people and you've seen this across
you know arielle scarcella who's on the
show yeah when she came out and said hey
i'm conservative like i've been
less progressive yeah and um you know
and seeing folks who are who have been
put into a box like if you have a
certain characteristic
you definitely like joe biden said you
got to be in a certain party you're
voting a certain way
but when you have talked to folks who
were adamantly progressive or whatnot
and then you were like hey i'm
conservative how did those conversations
go
not good i mean they're illogical you
can't have a rational discussion
with somebody who's progressive you try
to ask anybody on the left or
progressive or whatever they like to
call each other
today about any issue
they will never answer your question and
they will rationalize
they won't even answer their own reason
why they're concerned why they're
progressive or they just tell you i'm
i'm progressive because the riot is
racist and they're all white old white
man
yeah usually the conversation don't get
too far
right you're racist but that's changing
dramatically i don't
have this in front of me but i think we
can probably grab an overlay at some
point
and probably do a segment on this
generation z so younger black people
this just came out recently a study
compared to millennials or baby boomer
generation over 60. people who are under
the age of 30 black people are far
more amenable to the idea of a
republican president or
that the republican party is open-minded
to them it was something like
30-something percent
it was a high number whereas people
black people over 60
it was in the single digits that they
believed that the republican party could
be their home
and so people like you uh who really
stood to lose something i've talked
about this quite a bit there are
a lot of and not all of them but i know
a few but there are some really great
conservatives out there who
also happen to be black and there are
some where it's just their stick it's
just like it's almost like a
black conservative chris rock like well
black people you know what i mean
yeah yeah and you guys actually stood to
lose something because you had this
fitness brand you had been out for a
long time people were familiar with you
and you decided it was worth taking that
risk and that's something that i that i
applaud and i think that that moves the
needle a whole lot more
than someone who's never had a career
until they started wearing a trump hat
as a black person
yeah that was a major reason coming out
conservative i want to show black people
that hey
it's okay to think different you have to
think like everybody else just because
you're supposed to think a certain way
because of your skin colors
you're free to think however you want to
think you're an individual right yeah
just because the color of your skin
don't mean you have to be a democrat
yeah that's
that's a problem for black people they
think because they black they have to
think a certain way
they victimize each other and it's like
i don't think like you [ __ ]
you guys are actually insane this is the
best country in the world
there's millions of immigrants loot
trying to get here there's hundreds
losing our lives
just to get here and you're complaining
this is an evil place yeah tell you what
i'm gonna say something a white
supremacist is gonna tell you
go back to what you get if you don't
like it here
which is a logical question that's why
white people are asking well why are you
here
yeah if you don't like it there's a lot
of you could go to africa you look
y'all all gonna look just alike you're
gonna like it now yeah
yeah well yeah i got one one point on
myself like when we came out the closet
right and
our fan base totally changed it was like
60
little 70-30 white and everything else
now it's like
99 white yeah right and all the black
people who show up at our shows
the black dudes they're wise or white
i got this email this message on
facebook i just came across you
guys i saw y'all were black comedians
and i'm black so i want to come out and
support
and she said as soon as i get to your
show it looks like a clan rally
because everybody's white yeah and it's
like that's the problem with a lot of
black people they think with their skin
everything is based around race
everything that being said next time
your marquee shouldn't include a burning
cross you can't
it's like it's like a fly zapper for a
klansman
or a clan rally or a childish gambino
show yes either one yeah
[Applause]
i'm just gonna this is america
you know you don't need that there okay
go ahead yeah so i was just gonna say
the
insulting the people who disagree with
you are saying that everyone who
disagrees with me is
x or as some kind of horrible person is
the sign of a dying world view
it's a sign that you're on your heels
you don't have anything else you can't
defend what you actually believe it's
just a matter of
insulting the other well and you hear
even with the hot and i p people say
well go back to hajj and said no they
said it's illogical they said it's hard
to argue with because it's an illogical
response
which is what we heard from black
gentleman named king
at our last change of mind where he said
i hear what you're saying but you're
talking about facts he said i'm coming
from a place of emotion and i was like
are you are you are you writing a w up
on the scoreboard
which is not even when i was here i was
here to talk like you just you just
totally said like i am not capable to
actually discuss this without appealing
to emotion
and rejecting facts and that's that's
why it's hard to be apolitical today
because if you have people who think
that their opinion is just as
and of course everyone can have an
opinion obviously everyone has that
right but the idea that everyone's
opinion is just as valid
when it's someone who willingly offers
up mine is solely based on emotion
and it's just as valid as yours based on
history on data
on factual information on current events
right you have third party sources but
both of our opinions are valid because
i feel a certain way and melanin no
that's why it's hard to be apolitical
because people now assume
some moral superiority when they really
haven't earned it
regardless of skin color all right we're
going to continue these conversations i
have some more questions for the hodge
twins
again if you are not a mug club member
please do consider joining up because a
lot that we talk about
over there at mug club that we could not
talk about here on the youtube but for
right now
youtube it's time for you to uh urinate
uh outward